he's one of the best in the business
getting a new big fat contract from the
Dallas Cowboys well-deserved demarcus
Lawrence from the Dallas Cowboys here on
the Rich Eisen show how are you DeMarcus
hey how you doing I'm doing great
I just don't know how I could be any
better than you right now man I'm just
trying to live up to your name
don't stop now I don't put people down
on the ground I lift them up that's what
I think I like to do for a living
congratulations to you what does this
contract mean to you that you got
DeMarcus oh man it means a lot
meat slices you know me to what I can
bring to the cowboy organization it just
means I'm a part of a family you know
once again off you know I love the game
of football so much so the money you
know he's just supposed to you know
really comes with well how you play the
game so I'm just truly blessed to just
being this no position in my life so
what's your relationship with Jerry
Jones been like throughout this process
I mean I really thought that my student
process huh you know I was just gonna
let you know Dave handle you know all
the contract numbers and stuff and you
know my job is only to play football so
we would really want having our
discussions on but you know me and
Stephen had a couple of discussions on
it went very well you know that's how we
got to do it they're so very excited
you're referring to David Cantor your
agent so how are you feeling right now
DeMarcus what's going on with you
physically here man I mean you know I'm
still you know a little disbelief um you
know but I'm excited but you know I
don't want to get too ahead of myself on
I know I got a lot of football left in
me so it was all about you know I'm
saying make it enough you know I stick
and enough money is like to take care of
my family for a long time so that was
you know my whole point with the
contrary but it really wasn't about the
contract it is really about you know I'm
saying on the team you know believing in
me you know trusting into what I can
bring praying to them for the next five
years and the Cowboys did that no
not honored and you know truly blessed
you know still your cowboy
so are you gonna have surgery Wednesday
on your on your shoulder is that is that
happening yeah okay okay and then what
by when do you expect to be back for the
Cowboys all right
I can't quit no time tape on you know
how long it's gonna take me to recover
from the surgery you know but shoe I
should be back before the beginning of
the season okay so you're hoping that's
you know will you be back do you think
four or any preseason you just think the
first game of the season is is is a date
that you're circling to be on the field
with a star on the side of your helmet
what you want me to play I don't know I
just know what Cowboys fans are gonna be
saying they're all fired up and they're
nervous you won't be ready for the
season and you know I don't want to put
you in games you don't want to be in
demarcus see the thing with this whole
you know contract situation and
everybody wanted me to get my shoulder
done right
I think they keep the game that I played
was you know a broken bat two years in a
row and I don't think the pain and the
shoulder can ever match up to the pain
that I had to deal with with the back so
I don't really think it's gonna be an
issue only thing it could be an issue if
I try to rush it you know any and I
heard it again
not I mean so ain't no need to rush it
I'll I'll just keep working on my
fundamentals and you know trying to
become the best football player I can
I'll be okay couple more minutes left
with DeMarcus Lawrence the Dallas
Cowboys with a big new nine figure
contract from the Dallas Cowboys right
here on the Rich Eisen show so what what
what did you learn as a team the Dallas
Cowboys last year that you are going to
bring to the equation this year to
perhaps go further than the team got
last year
DeMarcus yes I mean we just have a lot
to build on just awesome you know those
last couple of games that we had um one
thing I just want to be able to
priesthood you know my guys and I'm you
know the organization is that we can't
start slow you know we got to come out
the gate
swinging you know and store these things
off right
you know there's hang on a lot you know
like when we got to the second round of
the playoffs our list or getting tired
you know we weren't able to play up to
our full abilities because it took about
us it took a lot out of us um and that's
the other game so we started fast you
know I'm still at a fireplace and the
division and uh we should be okay walk
me through who becomes a hot boy
DeMarcus you know I've heard about the
hot boys and and this whole process of
who decides who's in the hot boys and
who's not how does that work on your
defense right yeah you know China trying
to raise men trying to raise men ought
to fill in on the field in order to be a
hot boy huh you have to you know put in
work with your family you know you have
to I mean like we do like designers
every Thursday all Fridays it's best to
bring you know your white flowers or you
know whatever you know what I mean like
just at the end of the day like once
your football career over like your
family is all you got so it's all about
you know just raised a good man in this
world so that's that's all really what
the hot boy is about a press you know
you got to put in networks on the field
in order to be to become a hot boy so
wait I'll just let you become a hot boy
because you're a good man like you still
got to be a dog on the field so you know
it's a cool you know pushing cool you
know reaction you know with becoming a
hot boy so that's why it's a little hard
you know so can you can you be an
offensive player and do this can like
Witten just show up um since what he's
done for so long or obviously Zeke for
what he does or is this just a defense
thing
now it's just a deacon saying manly when
you let no offense players only get no
we might you know we might come to
agreement see so like it's just I just
cannot you know vote somebody in it has
to you know all come from everybody in
the group so once we you know initiates
you into becoming a hot boy like you
have a boat to you know so it's not just
no no one-man show okay two more
questions for DeMarcus because I know
you got to go here do you want to play
opening night in New England a lot of
people are trying to see if Dallas at
New England would be an opening Sunday
night game with the banner raising would
you want that invited LuAnn yeah for
Dallas yeah I'm definitely ready for the
challenge no talent don't tell me what
no good time now okay alright so you
would you would be up for that cuz it's
a tough it's a tough spot to be in
somebody's building when they raise the
banner you're up for that okay anything
one of the word daddy and I'm here okay
and now that you've gotten his aid for
the first time in your career what are
you gonna spend the money on is there
something that you the first thing that
you're doing with some of the newfound
cash for you DeMarcus uh not necessarily
basically you know just helping my
family you know I just put the rest back
that's not a bad thing to do hey
DeMarcus let's uh let's chat let's chat
more often okay I enjoyed this one and
congratulations on being paid alright
thanks man you got it congratulations
that's DeMarcus Lawrence for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV for free on BR Live or
download the Rich Eisen show app